If you want to hear how M Night Shyamalan
planted clues about Split and Glass way back
when he made Unbreakable in the year 2000,
then stick around to the around to the end
of this video.
Welcome aboard, this special episode of Things
You Missed.
And yes, I already know what you’re thinking.
No CZ, you can’t cover Unbreakable.
It’s not a horror movie.
OK, hold on.
Don’t tell me the scene at the Usmani family’s
house isn’t terrifying.
And second, I’m doing this because I’m
covering the entire series, which includes
Split.
A horror movie.
And also, I just want to do Unbreakable, and
it’s my channel and I can do what I want.
And if you haven’t seen Split, you’ll
want to have seen that as well as Unbreakable.
So with that being said, let’s take a look
at Unbreakable.
The first scene shows the birth of Elijah
Price, and we first see the child who would
later become known as Mr. Glass, through the
reflection of a glass mirror.
This is a common theme in Unbreakable, we’re
introduced to age 13 Elijah through the reflection
of the Glass television screen, and we’re
introduced to Adult Elijah through the reflection
of the glass in one of the pieces at his art
gallery.
When David meets Elijah for the first time,
not only are we looking through a glass window,
but the characters are framed in a box, just
like a comic book.
"Here by appointment only."
"I got a card from this store."
The reason for these choices is that Elijah
sees himself as nothing more than a fragile,
broken piece of glass, and his entire purpose
throughout the film is to find his real place
in the world, and discover why he is the way
he is.
In the next scene we’re introduced to the
protagonist, David Dunn.
Note the alliteration of his name like many
other superheroes: Clark Kent, Peter Parker,
Bruce Banner and several others.
One of the first moments of David being on
screen has him looking at a child in the seat
in front of him, who is upside-down.
Like the recurrent theme of glass, inversion
is also something that’s seen time and time
again in Unbreakable, and to understand it,
it’s important to understand the connection
between the film’s two central characters.
David and Elijah are opposites in every way
but one.
One is invincible, the other of as fragile
as they come.
One gets sick very easily, the other is never
sick.
One is physically gifted, the other has a
hard time even getting around.
David is light skinned, Elijah has dark skin.
David is very reserved, while Elijah is quite
outgoing.
And of course, David is the hero, while Elijah
is the villain.
So when all is right with the world, the camera
is upright, as it should be.
But when disaster is about to strike… when
something bad is about to happen, the camera
is inverted in relation to its subject, the
upside down girl precedes the train crash,
David’s son Joseph watches TV upside-down
before learning of the crash, Elijah lays
eyes on the comic book that first gives him
the idea that he’s a supposed to be a supervillain
and it’s upside-down, Elijah falls down
the stairs and sees the man with the gun get
away with an inverted perspective and Joseph
sees his dad lift an impossible amount of
weight from upside-down which later leads
him to pull a gun on his father.
There’s also an inversion reference hidden
in the credits.
David’s wife is named Audrey Dunn, but there’s
a separate credit for the actress who played
the age 20 Audrey before her and David were
married, where she’s referred to as Audrey
Inverso.
Finally, Elijah discovers a comic that helps
him find out what David’s kryptonite is
and that’s upside down as well.
Speaking of that kryptonite, that one weakness
that David has, David tells Kelly, the woman
he meets on the train, that he’s thinking
about getting into male synchronised swimming,
which is funny because we later find that
his weakness is water.
Director M Night Shyamalan also used the idea
of water as a weakness in his next film, Signs.
There’s also a connection to his previous
film, The Sixth Sense, in that Bruce Willis
is the star of both movies.
David’s wife also mentions that her favorite
song is Soft and Wet by the artist formerly
known as Prince.
Another word for soft is weak, and David becomes
weaker whenever he gets wet.
Kelly also asks David if he likes football,
and he says, “not really”.
We later find out this is a lie, David was
a huge football star, and he still works as
a security guard at his former school’s
stadium so that he can continue to be around
the game.
Kelly is going to Philadelphia to meet with
a cornerback from Temple University, who later
appears in the movie, he’s in the park playing
football with a bunch of kids, one of which
is David’s son.
One last thing on the train, this isn’t
confirmed, but I’ve got a hunch that this
could be Kevin Wendell Crumb’s father, who
is said to have disappeared on a train when
Kevin was young and never come back.
"But you've never met The Beast.
Because he doesn't reside with the rest of
you.
Because he resides in the trainyard, as the
story goes, because Kevin's dad left on a
train.
But the fact is: you and Patricia have never
met The Beast."
Alright, looks like this is my stop.
Alright, always good to be back.
So where were we?
After the accident, Joseph is seen watching
television.
"I don't know how close they're going to be
able to get David, there are woods and trees.
It's going to be a very difficult rescue.."
It starts with this Dole commercial featuring
a skateboarding Banana, then he flips the
channel to Jerry Springer, then the Powerpuff
Girls, which is a 90s superhero cartoon, and
then an episode of I Am Weasel, another 90s
cartoon, this episode is about a smart banana
that comes to life, it’s actually a really
funny episode.
I’m not entirely sure why there are two
separate references to a living, sentient
banana, perhaps an early foreshadowing of
The Horde, whose defining color is yellow.
Or maybe something with Banana Split?
Could be something there.
I should also probably explain the color scheme
for anyone who hasn’t seen my Glass trailer
analysis.
David is almost always wearing Green, from
his shirt in scene two to his iconic rain
poncho.
Elijah can mostly be found wearing purple
and the present from his mother is wrapped
in purple.
It even goes right down to Elijah’s purple
walled office and David’s kitchen with the
green cabinets, which looks beautiful when
complimented by the orange accents after David
defeats the Orange man… oh man we could
talk about color theory all day with this
movie, but let’s switch back to wherever
we were.
Right.
The TV.
The news of the train wreck comes in on channel
4 news, whose logo resembles the logo of the
Marvel superhero group, the Fantastic Four.
So David ends up being the only survivor of
the train crash, and after the memorial, receives
a note from Elijah, which leads him to discover
he’s never actually been sick.
Then we get the previously mentioned flashback
to Elijah’s childhood where he receives
the gift from his mother, a comic book titled
The Battle With Jaguaro.
Jaguaro is a beast like antagonist wearing
yellow and a reference to The Beast from Split.
Jaguaro is going up against a superhero wearing
green, obviously a reference to David.
“They say this one has a surprise ending.”
Yes, it does.
Elijah tries to sell the original artwork
as an adult, calling it a classic depiction
of good vs. evil.
However, when he learns that the buyer wants
to get this as a present for his kid, Elijah
is outraged.
And I love that little moment where Elijah
is explaining that this is an art gallery,
not a toy store, and he asks the prospective
buyer, do you see any Teletubbies in here?
And the guy actually looks, like “oh my
God, there’s no teletubbies in here!”
But anyway, after David meets Elijah, and
thinks he’s a scam artist, which is interesting
in itself considering David’s innate ability
to sense evil, David goes home and reads the
newspaper article about the train crash of
Eastrail 177.
The photo of the wreck is credited to Kevin
Ladson, and he's actually the prop master
of the movie.
In the article, the name of the transportation
secretary is Kia Dickerson, who is also on
the art department of Unbreakable.
Part of the article mentions that the trains
had just had an engine check prior to leaving
the station, an early hint that foul play
was involved.
On the right column, there’s an article
about raising money to build prisons
FOR YOU AND ME TO LIVE IN
Excuse me, to house the number of inmates
expected in the next decade, perhaps some
of the criminals caught by David Dunn will
inhabit these prisons.
Then David takes a look back at the newspaper
highlights from his football career.
One of the articles is written by Scott Murphy,
Shyamalan’s assistant art director, and
the photographer Jim Feng is a reference to
James Feng, another assistant art director.
Here’s another reason I love this movie,
always good to see the Brewers losing.
The article about David’s car crash in college
is written by Robert Holtzman, yet another
assistant set decorator.
He’s interrupted from reliving his glory
days when his wife comes knocking on his door
asking if David has been with anyone since
they started having problems.
“I’m prepared for any answer.
It won’t affect me.”
She’s lying.
“The answer won’t affect me.”
"It won’t affect me either way.”
She’s lying.
“No.”
Told you.
The next day at work, Elijah shows up and
we’re introduced to David’s ability to
sense bad people in a crowd, when he predicts
that a man wearing camouflage is carrying
a silver weapon with a black grip and that
he will step out of line, which he does.
Elijah sets out to see if David’s prediction
is correct.
He steps out of his car which is completely
covered in padding, in order to pursue the
guy, but on the stairs to the subway, has
a bad fall, and the shattering of his glass
cane represents his frailty.
I already talked about these scenes, so let’s
move onto the next stadium scene.
A single mother in red bumps into him and
he heads the sounds of child abuse.
Roll it like the spirit of Philadelphia.
“No….”
Maybe… just maybe… this kid is a young
Kevin Wendell Crumb from Split, but it might
be impossible to know for sure.
It is a different actress playing the Mom,
but is has been 15 years so it's just possible
that they weren't able to get that woman who
was an extra on set back to play the Mom.
I don't know.
Let me know what your thoughts on that are
in the comments though.
Then there’s a cameo from the director M
Night Shyamalan himself.
David is called away from work because his
son Joseph has an injury at school, when he
gets in a fight with two kids, who we later
find out are Potter and some other guy.
“It was Potter and another guy.
They were messing with this Chinese girl
in the dressing room.”
You may remember Potter is the cousin of the
Cornerback from temple.
“He’s Potter’s cousin.
He’s starting cornerback at Temple University.”
Then we’ve got Joseph’s gun scene.
Now supposedly this was inspired by an incident
that really happened to Superman actor George
Reeves, where a child confronted him with
a gun and asked to shoot him to prove Superman
was invincible, and Reeves convinced him to
put the gun down by telling him that someone
might be injured by the ricochet.
I don’t know if that story is true, but
either way it could have been used as inspiration
for the Unbreakable scene.
Finally, David revisits the wrecked train
cars and remembers the incident he and Audrey
went through in college, where we has actually
completely unharmed in the car accident.
He decides to become a vigilante, and saves
the two girls from the orange man.
In the newspaper article that comes out the
next day we find out that those girls were
tied up like that for 3 days.
The author of the article is Nicole Marsella,
of course an Art Department assistant.
Scott Murphy, the sportswriter from before
also has something to say about the breaking
up of farmland in this other article, so this
man has many passions it seems, and the farmland
stuff could be another hint towards Signs
being Shyamalan’s next film.
Finally, David visits Elijah’s art gallery
showing and meets his mother.
“See the villains eyes?
They’re larger than the other characters.
They insinuate a slightly skewed perspective
of how they see the world.”
These are just a couple final clues towards
the reveal that’s about to happen in a couple
minutes.
Elijah has always seen the world from a skewed
perspective through those big eyes of his.
But what’s truly amazing is her next comment.
“But he says there’s always two kinds.
There’s the soldier villain who fights the
hero with his hands… and then there’s
the real threat, the brilliant and evil arch-enemy…
who fights the hero with his mind.”
Shyamalan was planning to bring The Horde
from Split into the equation from the very
beginning.
In fact, he would later reveal that the horde
was at one point supposed to be a part of
Unbreakable, but he cut the character and
saved him for Split because the movie was
getting too crowded.
I’ve got one more Thing You Missed, but
first remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week.
Next week I’m going to be doing Things You
Missed in Split, and you definitely don’t
want to miss out on that, so make sure your
deathbell notifications are on.
The final freeze frame of the movie states
Elijah Price is in an institution for the
criminally insane.
Why would it say that if this is not a true
story, and Shyamalan wasn’t planning on
having Glass take place in that institution
19 years later?
I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.